what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are here with the return of superior
Spider-Man and at the end of this video
I will have a link to the playlist it
has Dan slot's entire Spider-Man run
starting with big time running all the
way up to uh clone conspiracy which
includes superior Spider-Man and the
spiderverse event so it's pretty hefty
17 years of Spider-Man but when it came
to Superior Spider-Man while Dr Octopus
kind of Muses here we could kind of
explain what was going on with the
nature of his character
so the way superior Spider-Man worked is
that it actually took place in a story
called dying wish which was kind of the
thing that kicked it off and the way
this played out was that Dr Octopus was
essentially dying right literally his
body was just shutting down it was hyper
aged all kinds of stuff and so as a last
ditch effort to both save his own life
and defeat Spider-Man he basically
swapped bodies with Peter Parker and he
took over the body of Spider-Man and
Peter Parker was forced into the body of
Dr Octopus now there was a little bit
more than that you know there was like
kind of a fragment of Peter Parker's
Consciousness which lingered for a while
and then eventually went away the
coolest thing about superior Spider-Man
is he initially started off as a bad guy
and then he became a Superhero by the
end it was really cool and in fact there
was a line of comics that I don't think
we covered called Superior foes of
Spider-Man I think that's what it was
let me know down in the comments because
I can't remember off top of my head
switching back to the moment he makes
his way to like this old lab that he
used to have with this kind of
containment device but he doesn't quite
recall what it was that took place that
led to this containment device's
creation or anything in the first place
and so he kind of takes a little bit of
a trip down memory lane and it's a way
for us to learn what's going on and so
what we do here is we jump back to a
point after he became superior
Spider-Man and it kind of seems like
it's at that moment when he's on that
precipice right he's kind of becoming a
good guy but not quite a full-on good
guy yet he's still just like a jerk that
talks to people with a level of huus and
it's hilarious but what he does here is
he actually starts asking his spiderbots
what it is that's going on throughout
the city of New York now that's one of
the things that made superior Spider-Man
a better Spider-Man than Peter Parker in
the sense that instead of just like
swinging around the city looking for
various crimes that what Dr Octopus had
done is he created spiderbots which at
all times were canvasing the city of New
York alerting him to various crimes that
were going on some of which he would
tell them to alert em mess sometimes
he'd tell them you know alert the cops
other times he would be like I'll go
respond to it and this is one of those
instances where there's just like a
villain who's doing villainous things
and because he's bored while he wouldn't
normally go after this guy at the very
least it gives him something to do and
so what he does is he comes across this
villain who if you've read Marvel Comics
for any measure of time this guy's name
is slide but basically the way he works
is his suit allows him to move on a
service with friction as if he is
frictionless right so in effect he's
almost impossible to touch right if you
try to grab him your hand will slide off
right he can like turn on a dime he's
incredibly agile he was a really cool
character that never quite got a lot of
respect within the realm of Marvel
Comics but the funny thing here is that
superior Spider-Man already knows who
this guy is and that where he kind of
puts off this idea that like he's going
after him the way that Spider-Man
traditionally would trying to find some
way to get his hands on him or something
along those lines it kind of gives slly
the impression that he has the upper
hand only to have the rug pulled out
from under him because what superior
Spider-Man says and this is a testament
to how intelligent his character was
he's like I know that I can't touch you
I never had any intention of putting my
hands on you I've just been steering you
and because of your stupidity you were
none the wiser to the fact that it was
happening and literally just like
because this guy is effectively sliding
on the ground what superior Spider-Man
did is he made a ramp out of webbing and
then this guy just slides up the ramp
and flat out into the water and because
he's frictionless if he stops moving
he'll sink down into the bottom of the
Hudson so he basically tells him like
take off your suit and it'll save your
life that's one of the big differences
is that Peter Parker would have tried to
find a way to save this guy's life
superior Spider-Man is like look man if
you decide to become a villain you pay
your money and take your chances and
there's no guarantee that I'm going to
even care enough to save your life right
superior Spider-Man was pretty hardcore
right he was pretty intense it was kind
of nuts but of course what this does is
it switches over to the aftermath the
slide's basically been webbed up but
what superior Spider-Man did is he stole
the trium that slide had on him as well
as taking his suit so it's one of those
things where he's still kind of doing
nefarious stuff now it's not outright
villain and again that was a big
difference between superior Spider-Man
in terms of how he started versus where
he ended this is kind of at that point
where it's just sort of like the ends
justify the means right like if my goal
is to do something genuinely great and
good then who cares how I get to that
point because Society will be better off
for it right the needs of the many
outweigh the needs of the few and
morality is a concept for lesser Minds
that was just how his character always
functioned whether it was right or wrong
is really kind of left up to
interpretation but having that just sort
of nature to its character always made
his stories fun and that's why he says
here right like with the supply of
tridium I may finally realize my
greatest scientific breakthrough a
miniature star grown under Laboratory
conditions a controlled Fusion reactor
generating Limitless energy it could
power the world revolutionize science
make me Rich beyond the dreams of
avarest so I can create other Marvels
for the betterment of humankind of
course right so again he's not a
straight up villain but he is kind of
doing some villainous things and so
that's why he said superior Spider-Man
is more of an anti-hero than a
traditional superhero and so with this
taking place in the moment at Horizon
Labs he ultimately ends up taking a
whole bunch of stuff back to the secret
laboratory now what's Horizon Labs right
as a quickest slide here Horizon Labs is
a think tank not that dissimilar from
like Reed Richards Future Foundation of
course Reed Richards from the Fantastic
4 for those of you guys who aren't
familiar with the name but uh it's it's
basically a giant thing tin and the way
this worked is that during Dan slot's
run before superior Spider-Man when
Peter Parker was just his normal self he
became part of horizon labs and their
Charter is to just think up really cool
stuff for the betterment of society but
if you think of dumb stuff they'll kick
you out right so it's it's kind of
interesting in terms of how it works and
so ultimately he's met with like Brady
scraps who was just kind of a goofball
he's really really smart but kind of a
buffoon at the same time and he's kind
of accused of like stealing stuff
nothing major going on here righty just
kind of lies to him and says well it's
my stuff but it's in Horizon lab's boxes
get out of my way now at that point you
switch over to Empire State University
and for those of you guys who have never
read superior Spider-Man you're
introduced to the person that was
actually the Catalyst that led to him
becoming a good guy this person of
course being Anna Maria Marone and she
developed a solid fan base in the
Spider-Man Mythos there are people who
love her character right because she's a
diminutive woman and she's the person
that initially was looked down on by
superior Spider-Man not trying to make a
joke here but in terms of him just kind
of looking at her he saw everybody as
being less than him but she was one of
the only people out there who would just
outright challenge him right and like
what makes you think you're as smart as
you believe you are and so because he
respects a person who's willing to
challenge him as well as a person who is
as intelligent as he is it led to
exactly what you think it would he fell
in love with her and so the result of
this is that he ended up kind of
changing his ways and becoming a hero
now this kind of takes place while
they're still in love or at least while
he's trying to court her in his own
weird Dr Octopus way but it's just kind
of introducing her character to us as
the reader and anybody who's not
familiar with with superior Spider-Man
but what he does here and even what she
suggests is like maybe you should like
have other people right or something
along those lines and where initially is
pitching the idea of just kind of being
like I mean like should I work for you
his response is like no like absolutely
has nothing to do with your size or
anything like that but the reality here
is like I want to spend more time with
you and so if you're working on this
whole project thing that's not going to
happen because the thing to remember
here when it comes to Spider-Man is
nobody knows his identity as Peter
Parker precious few people do and it had
been that way ever since the events of
Doctor Strange wiping everybody's mind
of Peter Parker's identity after he
revealed it during Civil War and so as
far as this whole situation goes he's
quote unquote developing technology for
Spider-Man that's kind of the ruse that
he uses here and so as this whole
project goes his stance is no no no no I
don't want to hire you on so that you
can work on with you know Spider-Man on
these projects because I want to spend
time with you I should hire somebody
else and and that's when he brings on a
girl named estrea Lopez right who is
actually an intern or at least was an
intern at the Future Foundation Reed
Richard's Whole Think Tank meaning she's
incredibly intelligent and so just
because of the fact that she like
pitches her level of intelligence and
whatnot he's just kind of like yeah
we'll bring you on right and you'll be
the person to Aid me in this entire
project now as the two of them are
working together they start to realize
that this project of trying to create a
miniature start is incredibly difficult
and they fail every step of the way all
the while they're in the process of like
running out of tridium so they only have
so much to work on not only that there
comes a point when AA gets back to her
lab and she's basically told by one of
the spiderbots hey there's a new suit
for you in your locker and when she puts
it on it's basically a spiderling suit
the spiderlings by the way were
basically Superior Spider-Man's own
henchmen that's really all they were and
so they kind of carry out his bidding
the issue here is that he needs more
equipment that was not readily available
at Horizon labs but is available by
Advanced idea mechanics right an
offshoot of Hydra that branched out to
do its own thing and focuses on
Conquering the world through
technological means this basically leads
to like the spiderlings and Superior
Spider-Man fighting against Advanced
idea mechanics which is not the most
significant thing but it is kind of cool
to see and that what he ends up doing is
that once he gets into their facility
they basically kind of take apart a
machine that was being used to basically
focus on particle and theoretical phys
and so on and so forth and they take it
back to his lab during that time they
get as close as they have been to
developing this miniature star only for
it to basically start losing cohesion
literally it's a bomb that's about to
detonate but because of its mass and
because of the amount of energy that it
has it'll wipe out everything within a
quarter mile so he ends up putting it in
this kind of stasis device right this
containment that we saw at the very
beginning of this story and then in turn
because they're running out of tritium
there's one last shot and so what ends
up happening as he's just kind of musing
with himself and trying to figure out
why it is that he can't seem to pull
this off the response of estrea is like
have you tried using the inverse of the
harmonic frequency to initiate the core
reaction what that means I have no idea
it's Greek to me I'm sure somebody out
there in the YouTube comments on this
video will be like here's exactly what
it means and if you do feel free to post
it man because I guess it means like
reverse of something I don't know I'm
not a science guy but what's funny about
this is Dr Octopus steals the idea as
his own he's like what if I use the
inverse of the harmonic frequency and
like his henchmen are like yeah man good
job boss which was kind of par for the
chorus when it came to like superior
Spider-Man like he was a dick he would
steal other people's ideas and it was
hilarious and so because he's quote
unquote come up with this idea on his
own he says like let's celebrate right
so he basically reserves a table for two
at Tavern on the Green which is a pretty
legitimate spot and then in turn he
invites Anna Maria Marone which pisses
off australa to no end because she
thought she was going to get the invite
and he's like not really and so the
result of this is that while you have
superior Spider-Man meeting with Anna
Maria Marcone and then just kind of
having dinner together right a romantic
night estrea goes back and just tries to
launch the experiment on her own and
basically be the one to develop that
technology and then take credit for that
technology the problem is that in true
Spider-Man comic sense the whole thing
goes sideways right she ends up dropping
the entire device just this energy goes
everywhere and power shuts down to
pretty much all of Manhattan and so when
superior Spider-Man gets back to the
laboratory he ends up finding out that
like Australia is basically powered by a
star and this is an astronomical amount
of energy right this is one of those
things it's always kind of funny the way
that Spider-Man comics do this you don't
really have Peter Parker fighting
against villains that like have the
ability to alter reality and with
superior Spider-Man Dr Octopus it was
pretty much the same way the inheritors
were about as far as you got with
regards to like some astronomically
powerful multiversal force that
represents like a true and definitive
end to any and all Spider-Man in
existence right like that's about as far
as you got what was a kicker here is
that this girl is ex extremely powerful
right right now with the level of power
she has she could annihilate pretty much
any superhero on Earth Thor maybe I'm a
little finicky on that the Incredible
Hulk I'm not 100% sure but like somebody
like wolver rain she'd reduce him down
to his own skeleton right like she could
kill the entirety of the Marvel Universe
and we know this just by way of the fact
that when she fires off a blast of
energy that takes virtually no real
effort on her part she blows multiple
holes through these just huge layers of
durable materials of course right human
brain the machine that helps to assist
superior Spider-Man ask anybody if they
care for a tasty beverage but this
basically represents the fact that the
amount of energy and heat that she's
letting off is basically the power of a
star itself she's not as hot as a star
but she can be and that's why she's one
of the most dangerous people in
existence because she's kind of like
Johnny storm right the Human Torch the
ability to become as hot as the sun
presumably we don't definitively know
because what ends up going on here is
that Dr Octopus pulls a ruse and the
reason why is because Dr Octopus crawls
into the containment device that he had
previously placed the star in and the
reason for this is he tells her like
you're moments away from exploding and
taking pretty much all of New York with
you right like the five burrows
everything and where she initially
thinks he's bluffing him crawling in
there comes with a statement he says I
need to find a place that will keep me
safe from your blast and the result of
this is that she comes to realize that
he's actually telling the truth she goes
in there and attacks him only to find
out that when she shoots him it was a
hologram that was created by a spiderbot
that Dr Octopus was actually outside the
room he immediately locks the door and
then he tells her like yeah so I mean I
wasn't lying when I said that you are
going to explode that's true but it'll
happen someday and with the level of
power you have you're basically a
walking talking star so it'll be about
like 3 and A2 billion years before that
happened so you're going to be stuck
here for like the next 3 and A2 billion
years in a giant Vault with nowhere to
go and no means of Escape so she's
literally trapped there and so the
result of this is that you basically
have him and the spiderlings that just
kind of like shut the whole project down
they scrap it and then walk away leaving
her there with no belief that like
anybody's ever going to stumble across
it Dr Octopus returns in his normal form
and while he doesn't really recall all
the details and everything that's going
on he does know he needs to open in the
vault to figure out what's inside of it
what it was that had happened here and
when he does estrea emerges but the cool
thing about this is that she sees Dr
Octopus and Dr Octopus sees her and he
recognizes her as asraa and that's when
it all floods back to him the whole
experience and everything and he begs
her not to kill him but then as far as
she's concerned it wasn't Dr Octopus who
locked her in this Vault it was
Spider-Man and in true re ridiculously
fun Spider-Man comic style her whole
stance is I'm going to go kill him I'm
going to go kill the WebCrawler and like
Dr Octopus is like yeah death to
Spider-Man but with that being said guys
we're going to bring this to an end make
sure you guys click this playlist to
cover the entirety of Dan slot
Spider-Man run it's phenomenal and I
will catch you all later peace